Hey, Conan 360 Live,
this is John Kourounis
from Warner Brothers
Studios Tour Hollywood,
and I'm currently in the
Warner Brothers Archive Museum
in the Harry Potter exhibit.
So, let's take a look.
First of all, see that owl.
We trained it to stay
perfectly, perfectly still.
It's acting like a security guard for us.
We also have the fireplace,
where Harry receives his
letter to go to Hogwarts,
he just wants to get an education
and be a good person, that's it.
We have first edition Harry Potter books
signed by JK Rowling.
Don't try to take these out of the case
because there's an alarm on it.
And as you can see, we also
have a Fantastic Beasts section.
We're gonna get to that.
Now, we're gonna take a walk around
and check out some of my
absolute favorite things
from all eight Harry Potter movies,
and also Fantastic Beasts
And Where To Find Them.
Let's go check it out.
Currently, we're in the Harry
Potter part of our exhibit
at the Warner Brothers Archive.
Now, truth be told, the
greatest part about all of this
is that's it's all the real deal,
these are the real costumes, real props
used in the productions, so
really worn by the actors
and the props really used.
Now, if you look all the way over here.
In Chamber of Secrets,
you not only meet Aragog,
but all of the descendants of Aragog.
If you have arachnophobia, don't look.
But real spider, the Acromantula.
We also have a Quidditch exhibit
and the Quidditch exhibit is not complete
without, of course, a
Nimbus 2000, right here.
Now, on this side we have original
Harry, Ron and Hermione
costumes, truly used in action.
They verified it.
And the greatest professors of Hogwarts.
We have Rubeus Hagrid,
we have Professor Snape,
we have Professor Dumbledore, McGonagall,
Professor Flitwick, I
want to go to Hogwarts.
But if you go to Hogwarts, you have to
get sorted in your house, right?
And guys, this is the real Sorting Sat.
So you come here, this is the experience.
Wear the Sorting Hat,
find out where you belong.
(blows breath) What's it gonna be?
(Harry Potter music)
[Sorting Hat] Conscientious
and hardworking,
a great thing to be.
Hufflepuff!
Hufflepuff?
(sighs) Supposed to be Gryffindor.
My parents are not gonna
be happy, that's fine.
And you can't talk about Harry
Potter without talking about
the Dark Lord, himself, Lord Voldemort.
If you back up all the way over here,
we even have their wands.
Now remember, the wizard
doesn't choose the wand,
the wand chooses the wizard.
We have the adult Voldemort, cool right?
We've got teenage Tom Riddle,
we also have young Tom Riddle
long before he is Lord Voldemort.
Now if you guys can see all the
way back here, that's Dobby.
Now, Dobby didn't actually exists on set,
he was completely done in post production.
So this is like a recreation so that they
kind had a point of reference.
Most of the time when they would
interact with Dobby on set,
they would talk to a tennis ball.
Random, I know.
Now, for those of you guys
that are big fans, excuse me, my dear,
we have Sirius Black, Gary Oldman.
Here's a fun tour fact for you.
Gary Oldman came to take the tour one time
and he was on the back of a cart,
nobody knew on the cart who he was,
which is hilarious to me.
The world of Harry Potter
is not complete, either,
without talking about how
artistic and fantastic and magical
the whole thing is, and we even
have some of their original
machetes of Fluffy the Three-headed Dog,
the Basilisk, the Hippogriff.
And even these things
that don't wind up on set,
you still have to create
them so that you have an idea
of what your world really looks like.
So, in my mind, this is a
tribute to true artists.
Now we're in the Fantastic Beasts
And Where To Find Them section.
We are standing in the presence
of Oscar winners my friends.
Take a look behind you.
This is a recreation of
Jacob Kowalski's apartment.
Dan Fogler played that character.
So you see the suit that he actually
wore to the bank to try to
get the loan, you see his bed,
the briefcase that sets
the whole thing off.
Is there a fantastic
beast in there? Who knows.
But you can see the open
one with the biscuits.
Don't try to eat them,
they're stale, I tried.
So his apartment is an absolute
disaster, kind of like mine.
In the distance you also see
Eddie Redmayne's character,
Newt Scamander, he's the
man, the myth, the legend.
Really, the focal point
of the entire movie.
We have Tina and Queenie Goldstein.
I looked for those dresses in
my size, that didn't exist.
Now, again, great things, guys.
Oscar winners for best
costumes, Fantastic Beasts.
If you haven't seen the movie, watch it
and then come check all this stuff out.
Now those are some of my favorite things
from the Harry Potter
exhibit, but of course,
we encourage you to come
see it for yourself.
So book your tickets,
go to WBStudioTour.com
and lay your eyes on these things too.
We'll see you soon.